مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره اقتحم
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيليه اثمار بن
كفير ومجموعه من المستوطنين باحات المسجد
الاقصى تحت حمايه الشرطه اقل بنجفير اثناء
الاقتحام ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه لن
تستسلم لتهديدات حماس وهذه اول عمليه
اقتحام لبنيكير زعيم الصهيونيه الدينيه
المتطرفه بعد توله حقيبه الامن القومي وقد
نجدت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
تنظم علينا مراسله الجزيره الان نجوان
السمري نجوان ضعينا فيه تطورات والتفاصيل
هذا الاقتحام الجديد لبن كثير
الان صباح الخير اذا هذا الاقتحام هو
الاقتحام الاول لبنك كبير سوازير
المتصرف الذي نصيب
الشرطه وزير الامن الداخلي حاليا لطالما
اقتحم المسجد الاقصى سابقا وهو قبل حتى ان
يذبح
والان همم
في عقاب محادثه مع رئيس الوزراء كما نشرت
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه همم قالت بانه
ارجع هذه الزياره لاسابيع اخرى
الى موافقه من رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيلي
يقدم على هذا الاقتحام على عكس ربما ما
شغله في السابق والاقتحامات السابقه التي
نفذها قبل ان يصبح وزيرا الوزير يتطلب الى
حمايه مجدده اكبر وبالتالي كان يحتاج الى
موافقه واقرار من بنيامين نتنياهو لكن
نشرت نساء بانه تم ارجاء هذا الاقتحام لكن
من الواضح انها كانت عمليه تضليل واضحه من
جهه بوسائل الاعلام ولكن تحديدا
في المسجد الاقصى
اعتذر منك الوقت الموجز انتهى تقريبا
سنتابع هذه النقطه لاحقا لكن في سياق
المنتصر وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
برصاصه في الصدر اطلقها عليه جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بيت لحم حيث
اقتحمت من الجيش الاحتلال جنين اليوم ايضا
واغلق تترقا ومحاور في المدينه وقالت
مراسله الجزيره من الشبكات المسلحه اداره
بين مقاومين وقوات الاحتلال التي حاولت
اعتقال مطلوبين لديها
انتهى الموجز في امان الله
[موسيقى]